most of um my teenage godchildren and
even the ones at University just
naturally assume their parents will know
where they are and I do think there's a
price to pay for that not least in the
for for the parents because if you're
always looking and I would be always
looking you know you're never really
letting them go you're not really
letting them develop Independence even
if they don't know it if you're sitting
there on on find my friends watching
them it does infantilize them a little
bit doesn't it if as a parent you're
always in that overseeing role
you're not letting them grow up properly
yeah and they may not learn how to make
their own plans independently or again
get themselves out of a difficult
situation yeah it just is a a different
quality of feeling when you're
completely alone and unobserved you have
to rely on your own resources don't you